[ __ ] Mike
[Applause]
wow
Jason Momoa strips down and flexes his
bare backside for the cameras it was the
time of my life Jimmy Kimmel Live
viewers got an eyeful on Wednesday when
the actor was wearing his costume for
his new Netflix film Slumberland welcome
to my world kid Slumberland you look fly
in this coat oh bro better in real life
than it is in the movie yes we're gonna
be in silk pajamas Slumberland get it
but the real show started when Jason
stripped out of that pink velvet coat
and those purple PJs during a chat about
this recent insta post when Jason went
fishing in traditional Hawaiian Malo I'm
doing a show I'm a Creator and writer
and director and producer and actor on
this apple series called chief of war
and it's all 1780 1790s Hawaii
that's what I wear every day and I was
just getting ready for the role because
I like to get into character and so I
was tanning my white ass is it just
you don't even like wearing clothes
anymore is that true it's I mean I'm in
it every day I wear it all the time are
you wearing this like under your clothes
right now
of course yeah you see where this is
going right
[ __ ] Mike
[Applause]
wow is right
it's the butt shimmy for me probably
will like it Ichi caught up with Jason
at the premiere for his flick this same
day and while he didn't take his clothes
off for the chat he did open up about
adopting a pet pig while filming in his
home state where's laulau the pig oh
he's in Hawaii it's a wild boar so I
couldn't bring him oh my God I saw an
Instagram video and I was like please
show up I know I think it would have
been it would have been pretty gnarly as
for Slumberland the film's about a young
girl who discovers a secret map to a
dream world with the hope that she'll be
able to see her late father again we do
so rule number three is just a bunch of
aggressive statements
nobody likes a smart alec kid and Jason
told E.T he had one very special reason
for doing this part this is the kind of
stuff I want my babies to see and this
is so unbelievable one they're the same
age so it's perfect
and they got along so which is great too
oh yeah
[Music]